[Music]
so today I'd like to talk to you about
what I call public risk management I
came up with using that term to avoid
the much more scary term regulation so
today's topic is gonna be talking about
public risk management for AI the path
forward and I'm actually going to
discuss quite a bit why I don't think
traditional regulation is going to work
and why I'm optimistic that that's okay
and that we're going to be able to
manage the risks associated with AI
without the need for direct government
intervention so let's jump right into it
what is a public risk well public risk
is a term coined by Peter Huber in the
1980s that I think in an article that I
think I'm the only person who read and
but it really struck a chord with me it
refers to potential sources of harm that
are centrally or mass-produced
or widely distributed and that are
largely outside the control of the
individual risk bearer so what does that
mean in plain English a public risk is
something that could potentially harm a
lot of people but the individual
potential victims have no way of
stopping the harm from happening so
examples of public risks that you all
would be familiar with include nuclear
technology mass-produced consumer goods
and environmental threats and mechanized
transportation these are all things that
meet those criteria above and I think
that many autonomous systems are going
to share those same features their
autonomous systems are becoming
increasingly ubiquitous in our lives but
there are technologies that most people
who use them are not going to have a
hand in their creation and are not going
to really be able to control the safety
aspects of them unless they are well
designed so that they can do so so as
you might have noticed from that list of
different forms of public risks public
risks didn't really exist prior to
industrialization at least of the human
generated variety so this is a
relatively recent phenomenon the concept
of public risk so the modern forms of
public risk management what we think of
as regulation were developed in response
to and because the fact that
pre-industrial institutions proved to be
fundamentally incapable of may
the risks and harms generated by
industrialization and there's a number
of social and economic reasons for that
but I think that everybody can agree
that by and large in the industrial era
there was a great centralization of
production of different of different
goods and services that people use and
that centralization meant that unlike
back in the day when your shoes were
made by the local cobbler and your toys
were made in your house they were made
by people thousands or hundreds of miles
away and you had no way of making sure
that what they were doing when they were
making that shoe and when they were
making that toy was safe so what we
ended up developing are a number of
different forms of risk management and
I've kind of created two axes here to
categorize them there's formal and
informal methods of risk management and
you could also call those governmental
and non-governmental and then
pre-emptive and reactive and you could
also think of those as ex ante and ex
post or immediate things that take
immediate effect and those things that
take time to kind of develop and usually
when people think of regulation they
think of the top two things in the top
left cornor legislation and agency
regulation I'm gonna spend today talking
about the different things on this chart
and why it's generally I think that it's
going to be challenging for these forms
of risk management to manage the risk
associated with AI the one thing we're
not going to talk about further that's
on this list is subsidies and that's
both because that is a not very coercive
and not very direct method of managing
the risk associated with technology and
also because I don't get the impression
that in the world of artificial
intelligence a lack of investment money
is going to be a serious drawback so
we're gonna focus on the remaining
things on this list and the big question
for AI risk management is whether these
pre these industrial er methods of risk
management are going to be capable of
managing the risks associated with
artificial intelligence and autonomous
machines so let's talk about why it's
going to be challenging
these various forms of risk management
first with short the shortcomings of
traditional formal regulations so that
would be the legislation and agency
regulations the things that we're in
that top left box in the table that I
showed you well one reason is that
machines are not people that's important
because all existing legal systems
operate by assigning and allocating
legal respond legal rights and
responsibilities to persons either
natural persons or corporate persons
corporate persons are the only widely
accepted form of person that is not a
human being
unlike previous generations of
technology autonomous systems are going
to be autonomous and that kind of
creates a unique challenge for the legal
system because they're not used to
autonomous agents that aren't people
that are potentially causing harm there
are other aspects of traditional or
excuse me of AI that I think is going to
make it difficult to manage the risks
associated with them through traditional
regulation and largely these remaining
ones have to do with the way in which
research and development work in AI can
be done and as you'll see they're also
shared by other information age
technologies and there's four of them
that I want to talk about in the first
is discreteness spelled with an e ET and
that refers to the fact that risky
development work could be done in
locations and using methods that escape
detection by regulators as you might
have noticed those examples of public
risks that were on the first slide that
I showed you it's hard to do nuclear
technology research and it is hard to
mass-produce consumer goods without
leaving a large physical footprint of
some kind there other traces and
footprints in the sand that regulators
can use to figure out where the harm is
coming from and who is responsible for
generating it that's not necessarily
going to be the case with artificial
intelligence
as with other Information Age
technologies you can do work on an
artificial intelligence system without
leaving a large physical footprint
without large
visible infrastructure in place there's
also a discreteness with an ete problem
and this form of discreteness refers to
the fact that the risk might stem from
the interaction of components that are
created at different times in places
without conscious coordination think of
the machine learning libraries on github
if those get incorporated into a system
it's kind of hard to say that there was
one person who is responsible for
designing that machine learning library
and it's even more difficult to say
excuse me you can't even necessarily
hold them collectively responsible
because they may not have coordinated
with one another in any sort of
conscious way commits to github can
obviously be made without the person who
makes one commit having checked with the
person who made the previous commit to
see if they're okay with it so the next
issue is diffuseness this is closely
related to that last issue of
discreteness and that refers to the fact
that designers and manufacturers of
components and the people who have input
into coding may be in different
jurisdictions and the operators of the
technologies might end up being in yet
other jurisdictions the last issue is
opacity and that's exactly what it
sounds like and that simply means that
regulators may not be able to discover
or understand the underlying mechanisms
that create the risk so these problems
are what led me to question the ability
of traditional formal regulation to
manage the risks associated with AI well
why can't we just leave it to the free
market why not just let consumers go and
buy AI products and then those that end
up killing members of their family don't
get purchased again in the future well
there's a few problems with that and as
you'll see these are issues that are not
at all a new phenomenon as far as
challenges for free market risk
management one is information asymmetry
and I place a lot of weight on this one
personally producers have more
information about the potential sources
of risk in their products than consumers
do I have a feeling that this is going
to be particularly cute with it acute
with AI just as it is for other emerging
technologies when the technology is new
usually the people who are creating that
tech
the innovators are the only people who
are going to have a full proper
understanding of how it works so and
certainly consumers who have not
interacted with that technology before
are not going to have an proper
understanding of the underlying
mechanisms by which it works that allows
them to assess the risk associated with
it
so that information asymmetry that's a
failure in the free market that results
from inter excuse me back up failures in
the free market that resulted from
information asymmetry are a large part
of why the regulatory state was
developed it was meant to be some great
equalizer that allowed consumers to be
protected because there are particular
government agencies and institutions
that did have the knowledge about the
public risks and that we're able to
develop rules that were able to manage
those risks even if the individual
potential victims didn't have a full
understanding so what about insurance
this is something that I've struggled
with a little bit I think that certainly
insurance offers some promise as a
method of risk management for AI but the
problem is that it's difficult to
estimate risks associated with new
technologies you usually have to have a
track record in order to accurately
assess what the risks are and it's
difficult to insure against large-scale
public risks obviously if the Three Mile
Island nuclear
almost meltdown had actually developed
into a full meltdown
whatever insurance companies were
involved in that would have had a very
difficult time meeting their obligations
and that's true in law in many cases for
a wide variety of public risks and
that's why insurance is generally not a
adequate method of managing the risks
associated with public risks so what
about industry standards and self
regulation I actually think I used to be
quite skeptical of industry standards as
an effective form of risk management for
the reasons that I talk about on this
slide but then I'm gonna move into why I
think
there's actually a some very good
reasons to believe that industry
standards could be an effective form of
risk management for AI so what are the
traditional shortcomings well the first
is the fox guarding the henhouse problem
industry effectively decides the
acceptable level of risk for the public
when dealing with industry standards
that only works if the industry's
interests are largely aligned with those
of society at large and that is rarely
the case for large companies which
traditionally generate most public risks
another issues enforcement market
participants can avoid the restrictions
imposed by industry standards simply by
leaving the rulemaking body that sets
those standards or by never joining that
body in the first place
and so what you usually end up with with
self-regulation is one of two outcomes
you either have weak and ineffective
standards or you have strong standards
that are never enforced well could it be
different with AI here's the reasons
that I am optimistic that industry
standards could actually be effective in
the case of AI first is that we've seen
early buy-in from key industry players
industries not waiting for the harm to
occur before making the move in
assessing the risks associated with
autonomous systems that's pretty unusual
for new technologies usually producers
don't want to go out ahead and create
the perception that there might be risks
associated with their technologies by
preemptively discussing the safety
aspects and the safety challenges that
it presents we're seeing a level of
awareness of that that with AI that you
haven't seen with earlier generations of
public risks and this is reflected in
private sector initiatives encouraging
transparency and beneficial AI such as
the partnership on AI the open AI
project and we also have broad
stakeholder participation in these
initiatives and the AI community has so
far been very welcoming of input from
policy ethics and legal experts and
those stakeholders are often having a
direct role in those current initiatives
that are underway that means that the
industry standards
it could be developed might align better
with those of society at large than
traditionally is the case with industry
standards and self-regulation and also
there's an emerging consensus around the
goals of what we want to see as far as
beneficial artificial intelligence and
that was beautifully reflected with the
survey results yesterday so there's an
additional reason that I'm optimistic
though those things by themselves would
be good but when industry standards have
a strong degree of consensus they can be
amplified by the common law and I'm
going to try to summarize what the
common law is in about 15 seconds and
that's not easy but the common law is a
system where legal rules don't come from
fixed legislation but instead develop
organically from precedents derived from
the resolution of individual disputes so
if in one dispute they say you have to
clean up a spill on aisle four within 10
minutes and if you don't you're
negligent then the next court that comes
along is going to look at that prior
case and say well you didn't clean up
that spill on aisle four within 10
minutes so you were negligent and what
this allows is kind of a slow
development of legal rules about what
behavior is acceptable and what behavior
is not this is the dominant legal system
in the english-speaking world and
elements of the common law are becoming
increasingly prevalent in a number of
other countries and the key mechanism
for the purposes of risk management with
emerging technologies is tort law tort
law is a broad area of the law and one
feature of it is that all people have a
duty of care to avoid causing harm when
they're engaging in activities that
could potentially lead to harm when true
industry consensus emerges and those
that consensus is reflected in written
standards those standards can
effectively become the law through the
adoption by common law courts as part of
that duty of care to avoid causing harm
that hasn't happened as often as I think
should have over the course of the
industrial era in part because that
industry consensus is very hard to
achieve and it rarely emerges early
enough for it to be incorporated before
legislation and age
see regulation preempts the field I want
to talk a little bit about some current
developments that are going on that are
also specifically giving me hope that
there's actually movement happening with
industry standards that could lead to
effective risk management for AI a lot
of them are happening at the I Triple E
the I Triple E has a global initiative
for ethical considerations in AI and
autonomous systems it's an initiative
that is divided and committees focusing
on different aspects of ensuring
ethically aligned design they produced a
draft version of a draft version of
basically the goals and potential
standards that the initiative could lead
to last month and that is currently in
the public comment period and this is
the time to engage and provide input on
what ethically aligned design should
look like for AI a sample standard that
I want to talk about there's certainly a
lot of standards that could potentially
come out of this initiative but one that
is currently underway is transparency
and autonomous systems that's a goal
that while there's some controversy that
seems to be a large amount of interest
in transparency and AI and this is a
standard that is going to encourage
transparency to a wide range of
stakeholders and it recognizes that
transparency is going to mean different
things for and different things to
different groups of stakeholders and I
listed some of the stakeholders that are
in mind in the previous paragraph there
the previous bullet point now I think
that there's a general consensus as I
said that openness is good but being a
lawyer and a former law clerk for a
judge I can't resist noticing noting for
the purposes of fairness the potential
shortcomings of openness and that is one
is intellectual property concerns the
usual industry standards way of getting
around that is to have licensing under
fair reasonable and non-discriminatory
terms that isn't so useful if the tech
can easily be pirated another security
concern
and openness could give bad actors a
blueprint on how to do harm other
current developments there are a couple
of things and I'll just go through these
quickly
two of them are being spearheaded by
Wendell Wallach and they are essentially
governance coordinating committees which
is a proposal that he and Gary Marshawn
made a couple of years ago it's an
institutional mechanism for coordinating
risk management efforts and there is a
national initiative that is kind that is
currently underway and Windell has just
spearheaded reece more recently an
international effort in coordination
coordinating with the Hastings Center in
the Carnegie Council for Ethics and
International Affairs so you can to act
as an issues manager for institutional
stakeholders worldwide we're also seeing
a number of sector specific initiatives
in areas such as autonomous weapons and
autonomous vehicles
so in closing the momentum that is being
generated by this conference and others
like it must not only be sustained but
intensified we can't stop with general
statements of principles we have to be
concrete about the goals that we want to
achieve and we have to be concrete about
what it means to have safe and
beneficial AI this is a rare opportunity
here to shape policy without going to a
government for approval so the bottom
line is this is I I think it's easy to
lose sight at these conferences of what
a rare opportunity there is here this is
the most important invention arguably in
the history of mankind and the people in
this room have the ability to shape the
way that policy develops for that
technology that's in once in in more
than a generation that's once in
multiple lifetimes opportunity so don't
fear law policy and ethics people engage
them and engage with each other that's a
great overview Matt thanks very much and
one thing you didn't touch on was that
dynamic with society in general and you
know we've learnt over the last 15 20
years that the social dynamic social
trust social accountability are critical
in terms of creating barriers for
technology innovation or enabling it you
just say a little bit about
how you see that aspect of things around
engagement trust and accountability fit
again with your governance ideas well
one thing that we do have to bear in
mind that these conferences is that we
are to a certain degree breathing
rarefied air you know the broader the
the man on the street as it were the
people who say elected Trump is
president or not in this room by and
large and we need to bear that in mind
when we're thinking about how society is
going to react to the standards that we
have and so I guess I should have added
to my talk and say we shouldn't just
engage with each other and with the
policy experts that are in this room we
should seek out and make sure that we're
hearing the concerns of people who we
ordinarily wouldn't even think of
inviting to conferences like this and if
we don't do that then there's a very
real risk that whatever standards we
develop are going to eventually be
rejected by the legal system because
indem in democracies if people don't
like the way that industry is regulating
itself they create pressure for the
government to regulate it for them yes
yeah we talk about AI systems autonomous
systems this is something it will happen
sometimes in it may be in the near
future but hasn't happened yet there are
two autonomous systems already been
deployed it's the Google search an
algorithm in the Facebook News & algorri
a hugely influential algorithms and so I
have a hard time being optimistic about
the self-regulation where the things are
already deployed have escaped any so far
any regulation whatsoever including any
industry regulation I understand the
reasons the reasons to be skeptical of
the effectiveness of this sort of thing
but I really do think it is still early
days and there's still plenty of space
and time for us to develop standards
that can ensure the benefit the
beneficence of AI question that
this may be the last question okay Vince
connoisseur Duke University so a little
while ago some of our law students
participated in this mock trial about
autonomous vehicles and some of this
came down to which information would
personally identify you today we're
talking about this very sensibly but as
it turned out they hadn't actually
thought of the fact that trajectory
information would personally identify
you and so my question is do you think
we're doing enough to train young
lawyers not just in sort of the abstract
concepts involving this but also just
concrete technical aspects that would
allow you to answer such questions no I
don't think that we're doing enough for
that and it's difficult to get law
schools to teach law students about
practical things to begin with and I
think that that's especially challenging
with new technologies and I completely
agree that's something that there should
be more awareness raised in law schools
that these legal issues are things that
law student should be examining now
because they're the ones who are going
to be both help shaping the policy in
the future and representing clients and
individual cases where they're at issue
[Music]